In general, coding region SNVs are more likely
to cause problems than non coding SNVs. Because there's
more of a risk of changing the amino acid
sequence of proteins. Which is going to alter their function.
For example, take this sequence from the ABO gene
that determines blood type. We talked about this gene
in lesson three. Now, if this particular sequence. Were
transcribed and translated starting right here at the start,
code on region ATG. Based on the
genetic code that we learned about previously in
lesson three, we would obtain a protein sequence
of methyianin, valine, arginine, valine, valine, and threonine.
We got this by essentially dividing our sequence
up into codons that we could read with
our genetic code. Now take a look at
these three different mutations from the original sequence.
I want you to rank these single nucleotide variatons in
order of what you think the most severe change would be,
by numbering at number one. To the least of your
change by numbering it number three. Use the numbers one, two
and three to put into these boxes right here, ranking
these particular SNVs. And don't forget to use the genetic code.
There's a link to it on this page but you
can look it up or you can print it off and
keep it handy because we're going to need it
for the rest of this lesson for sure.